Telekom. Telekom. Einfach Fritzbox abgekackt, ey.
Oah.
Fuck.
Telekom. Drecksladen, ey.
Moment. Defendet ihr das gerade ohne mich? Kann das sein?
Ja.
Easy.
Kein C9 jetzt. Kein C9. Easy.
Okay. Ähm. Ja.
Es lag jetzt nicht in meiner Macht da was dagegen zu tun.
Telekom.
Ich komm mal, ob das Stream wieder läuft.
Ob das Stream läuft, oder?
Ja.
Oah man, Telekom.
Ja. Da sagste was. Das ist was das für ein...
Weißt du, das ist mega frustrierend.
Ich hatte erst Unity Media. Mit denen konnte ich, weil ich
nicht genug Upload hatte, in ordentlicher Qualität streamen.
Also es wäre theoretisch nicht das funktioniert.
Allerdings hätte ich maximal 5 MBit gehabt. So. Für'n Arsch.
Jetzt hab ich Telekom, hab richtig viel Upload, Bandbreite,
VDSL, aber
Abbrüche. Was ist das?
Und zu richt... Also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie
paar Pakete verloren gehen. Das DSL trennt
die Synchro... Das trennt einfach. So. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Ja, ist bei mir auch so.
Drecksladen, ey.
3 Wochen oder so.
Telekom. Ihr habt einen Job, ja?
Ihr habt einen Job.
Den kriegst du dann halt hin.
Drecksladen.
Hast du nicht auch ab und zu mal ein Paket drauf? So immer ganz kurz
ein Paket oder so. Also ich hab manchmal Lacks, aber das ist
einmal am Tag gefühlt. Da springen auch richtig die Helden
hier rum. Was waren das nochmal? N, Steuerung N,
Shift N. Ne, was war...
Steuerung Shift N, ja.
Steuerung Shift N.
Nö, jetzt ist top.
Also ich seh bei mir manchmal dieses Paketverlustzeichen
links oben auf. Ne, das hab ich nie.
Muss man das extra einschalten oder ist das nur standardmäßig an?
Äh, das musst du glaub ich einschalten.
Netzwerkinweise oder irgendwie so was. Ja.
Alles klar. Gucken.
Ich mein, ich...
Weißt du was ich machen könnte? Ich könnte...
Ich könnte streamen über Telekom, aber das...
Aber spielen über Unity Media.
Oh shit, hier oben ist die Dumpfist.
Ich hab ihn.
Weckt. Gott sei Dank.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir dich trotzdem verrecken können, ne?
Ey, wo kommt denn jetzt die Ferne her?
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh, knapp.
Need help.
Ich bin down.
Puh.
Ich versteh das manchmal nicht, wo die Gegner herkommen.
Ich überleg grad, was könnte ich denn anderes spielen?
Hitscan. Ne, wobei wir brauchen keinen Hitscan.
Wir haben...
Wir haben Widow.
Ja, Strike.
Und Bastion.
Schon wieder Dumpfist.
Ich kann nix machen von unten. Ich kann pushen.
Was ist das, man?
Ich hab diese Metra.
Okay, jetzt haben wir sie.
Ich drück die ganze Zeit einen Tealing,
aber es kommt keine Nachricht zu euch.
Und jetzt sagt ihr mir zu, wenn ihr messen wollt.
Okay.
So broken teilweise.
Ich dachte schon, der Stream kommt nie wieder.
Ja. Ey, einfach so abhauen mach ich ja nicht.
Okay.
Mach ich ja nicht.
Die haben Tele? Kann das sein?
Hat sich ausgetelet.
Ich bin gesleebt.
Ja.
Lichtuhr.
Wieder Overwatch. Diesmal
Duo. Ist nicht ganz so tiltlastig.
Wenn die Telekom mitspielt.
Hanzo, hallo.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Der Bastion ist ein wenig nervig.
Oh, kommt gleich der Doomfist.
Der wird gefisst in der Doomfist gleich.
Vom Rolltalk.
Komm her.
Nö, hat keinen Bock.
Lall.
Haben die Gegner keinen Bock.
Wer kann das sein?
Doomfist hinter dir. Ich seh dich nicht.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Der macht nichts anderes.
Außer die ganze Zeit nichts zu hören.
Meteor Strike.
Was?
Den hab ich nicht getroffen.
Wo sind denn die Leute?
Der ist schon wieder rechts oben.
Kannst du da rechts hoch gehen bitte?
Ja.
Heiß.
Wenn ein Held noch lowskilliger ist, dann der da.
Von einem Stun in den nächsten.
Das ist gut.
Wo ist der dreckige Doomfist?
Oh, ich bin gesleept.
Ich kann damit nicht viel gegen machen.
Ich kann hier ab und zu mal hooken.
Aber das war's.
Aber die Gegner spielen auch schon gar nicht mehr richtig, glaube ich.
Du musst echt mal Werbung für den Stream machen.
Warum?
But why?
Ich bin auch kein Partner.
Dann lohnt sich das dann immer.
Der kommt schon wieder zu mir.
Ah!
Der Doomfist geht mir auch mega auf den Sack.
Hallo, Doomfist sterben, please.
Ich möchte einen Heal brauchen.
Und wieso bist du kein Partner?
Weil du keinen Partner hast.
Weil du keine Werbung für den Stream hast.
Weil ich mich nicht performen habe.
Und aktuell auch keine Ambitionen drauf habe.
Also ich versuche jetzt blabberde zu bleiben.
Du hast ihn gerade schon gebashed.
Ach komm ey, ich schieße ja alles low.
Ich schieße ja alles low.
Sag mal, was ist denn das hier gerade wieder für ein Scheiß?
Wir brauchen einen Tank.
Warte mal.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, was hier abgeht.
Wie habt ihr das denn überhaupt defended?
Keine Ahnung.
Hallo Moira, du darfst mich heilen, Moira.
Das ist erlaubt.
Hallo, hallo.
Ich habe aber keinen Bock drauf.
Kommen wir mal an Slankerino.
Ah, mach den Winston weg.
Pushen, pushen, pushen.
Jetzt aber.
Winston am Cart.
Wo ist er?
BÄÄÄM
Nee, ich habe ihn gerückt.
Sag mal, das gibt es doch nicht.
Pushen, pushen, pushen.
Wie habt ihr das gehalten?
Wir sind ja untergegangen gefühlt gerade.
Wie habt ihr das zu 5 gehalten?
Frag mich nicht.
Jaja, der mich auch.
Ich habe auch leicht reden, wenn ich einen Noobheld spielen kann.
Mit 10 Stunts.
Vor allem, du hast ja auch nicht wirklich viel Support gehabt, muss man mal sagen.
Ich habe dir den ab und zu mal gehuckt, aber das war's.
Kriegt Roadhog auch 50% weniger Schaden beim Trinken, wenn er lila ist?
Gute Frage, ich würde vermuten, ja.
Weil sich das lila eigentlich normalerweise nur darauf bezieht, dass du nicht geheilt werden kannst.
Du hast ja auch weiterhin Damage Absorb von Rüstung und sowas.
Also ich würde mal vermuten, ja.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert.
Oh, wir haben Instant Game.
Oh, schöne Map.
Tivics Lieblingsmap.
Defense.
Soll ich dich heilen?
Wobei Zen da, wer ich weggesnipet, macht ja ja keiner.
Keiner was.
Someone gut Main-Tank.
Nein, aber ich spiele trotzdem.
Nein.
Ich bin kein gut Main-Tank.
Ich kann nur Main-Tank spielen.
Ja.
Was ist dein Name?
D.Va.
Rusti
Dreamtank.
500 Diamond, Hansel.
Der wird es bestimmt bringen.
Wo ist denn mal der?
Das sind ja immer die Spieler, die da teilweise mehr Playtime haben als die Pros in zwei Jahren.
Die haben...
Tivic ist...
Oder war das Tivic?
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendjemand hat letztens im Stream mal Silber gekriegt.
Also das Silberrang.
Also weiß-weiß-mein halt unten dieses Symbol, wo es dann so silber wird.
Nach zwei Jahren spielen, weißt du?
Patrick, normalerweise wird schon mehr gelabert in-game.
Aber ich bin die ganze Zeit nicht in Voice Chat gewesen.
Und ich gehe jetzt...
Ich gehe auch wieder raus, weil es wird schwierig mich darauf zu konzentrieren.
Warte, ich lasse...
Da mach ich nix mit meinem Schild, solange er nix reinkommt.
Der Winston!
Rotor kommt unten links lang.
Unten links, unten links der Rotor.
Da kann einer die Mercy wechseln.
Fahrer ist links.
Mit TF!
Help!
Schild bricht, Schild bricht.
Ich brauch Heal! Heal, please!
Oh, ich hörte auch einen, die von dir kommt.
Okay, Barrier ist kaputt. Ich muss mich mal verpissen.
Er ist richtig kaputt gegangen.
Was ist das jetzt?
Ich wollte gerade ein Schild holen.
Schild, Schild, Schild!
Ich muss mir mal ein Schild holen.
Ach, wir haben gar keine Mercy!
Mit TF!
Dachte, dachte wir auch eine Mercy.
Ah, komm.
Der Nado boostet Hanso!
Ach, wir haben jetzt den Spacko im Team.
Ich switch mal D.Va.
Sonst wird das nix.
Ich hab die Fahrer erwischt mit dem Fire Strike.
Aber mehr ging da nicht.
Wer ist denn da Spacko?
Okay, das könnte was werden.
Wir müssen bloß auf dem Punkt bleiben.
Nice stun!
Sehr, sehr nice!
Ich switch wieder auf was mit Schild.
Oder zeig mal, was haben die denn?
Eigentlich brauchen wir nicht so wirklich den Schild, ne?
Die haben Flanker, die haben noch Fahrer.
Und Roadhog.
Ich bleib mal auf D.Va.
Das ist wirklich großartig.
Poke-Damage haben die nicht.
Moment! Warum sterben alle?
Keine Heilung wieder mal.
Ich geh gleich auf Sorgen.
Was willst du denn da machen?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Da ging jetzt wirklich nicht so viel.
Gucken, Spiel-Support.
Wieder meine ultrakrassen...
Jetzt wird der Sen ausgepackt.
Nein, jetzt wird nicht der Sen ausgepackt.
Die Mercy wird ausgepackt.
Ja, okay.
Kackheld, ey.
Ich hoffe, die nerven den so kaputt,
dass ihn keiner mehr spielen will.
Was heißt spielen will?
Spielen muss.
Von spielen will kann mir ja keine Rede sein.
So, ich bin völlig isoliert.
Chat aus, Voice aus.
Perfekt.
Hast du schon mit Qt gearbeitet?
Ja.
Doch, ich lese aber gerade meinen Chat.
Das ist interessanter.
Also, Evoli hab ich, ja.
Sie knallt Slots.
Ist ein bisschen wie in Event, sind sie sharp.
Das ist Gewöhnungssache.
So ne Idee, wie man Mercy balancen könnte.
Also, Nebe einfach so scheiße machen,
dass sie raus, dass sie keiner mehr spielt.
Ja, was meinste?
Alle Patches löschen,
bis zum 50% Discord auf.
Dann spielt sie auch keiner mehr.
Das ist glaube ich
kein, aber das ist glaube ich kein
realistischer Ansatz.
Was?
Hallo, oh fuck, der geht rein.
Okay, ich geh jetzt mit unserem
Roadhog, ich geh jetzt mit unserem Roadhog.
Move dich, sag mir mal wo du bist.
Oben auf der Wand,
auf der Mauer.
Auf, movet euch,
Leute, movet euch.
Da ist ein Reaper direkt über uns, ne?
Ich hasse diesen Held, ich hasse ihn so sehr.
Drecksheld.
Moment, das ist gar...
Oh, oh.
Ich bin echt...
Perfekter Mercy-Play,
Perfekter Mercy-Play, Max.
Man sieht schon, wie oft ich hier stehe.
Ich hab den Fight eigentlich verloren.
Was geht mit der Mercy ab?
Ja, Damage boost.
Roadhog, Roadhog, ich kann nicht zu dir fliegen.
Ich seh nix, danke Hanzo.
Ja, Hanzo.
Reaper kommt da.
Ich wette, du merkst wie cool Mercy ist, wenn du Mercy mains.
Ich sag euch eins, ich werde nie im Leben vorher deinstalliere ich Overwatch bevor ich Mercy maine.
So ein Kackheld.
Kannst du mich healen?
Wenn du euch auf Damage boost geben.
Ja, mach ich.
Äh, nein, mach ich nicht.
Und dann ganz Damage boost bitte.
Ich komm, muss zu dir hoch.
Ich komm nicht zu dir hoch.
Roadhog ist down.
Ich muss mal kurz unseren Typ heilen.
Echt jetzt?
Der Reaper hat gerade den Full Headshot überlebt.
Macht es nicht 300?
Achtung, da kommt was zu dir hoch.
Äh, nein.
Vergiss es, kommt es nicht.
Wieso ist denn keiner auf dem Spot?
Ich hab gerade vier Leute gesnipert.
Weil keiner da ist.
Jetzt hab ich einen Genji auf mir drauf.
Kannst du mich heilen?
Hinter dir.
Ach, die haben Shield schon.
Deswegen ist der Reaper nicht draufgegangen.
Ich seh ihn.
Place!
Nein!
Was macht denn die Meurer? Kann die auch mal was heilen?
Oh Mann, der Genji solo ultet mich.
Ich frag mich, der Fight ging noch wieder 5 Minuten, weißt du?
Hat eigentlich keiner den Shield-Shade down gemacht?
Keine Ahnung, ich war zu sehr damit beschäftigt, mich auf diesen Hero hier zu konzentrieren.
Um Huge Mercy Plays zu machen.
Ich bleib jetzt mal auf dir drauf.
Ich bleib jetzt mal auf dir drauf. Ich muss mal die Leute halten.
Ich geh mal auf den Spot.
Was?
Die Mercy!
Die Mercy ist so krass, oder?
Du bist unsterblich.
Movement des Todes.
Du kannst wiederbeleben, heilst dich selbst und machst Damage.
Warum?
Nein, ich mach keine Mercy mehr.
Ich fühl mich richtig dreckig, wenn ich Mercy spiele.
Übrigens, hast du die Maywall am Ende gesehen?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Maywall hat eben das Game verloren.
Richtig schlecht.
Widow, did you kill one guy?
Ich hab alles auf Gold, wenn du mich so blöd fragst.
Oh Mann ey.
Der Typ ist einfach nur daneben.
Can you stop bullying our good player schreibt der andere jetzt zum Hanzo.
Kax, can I hog?
Ja, kannst du. Du kannst hoggen.
Ich spiel jetzt Ana. Ich spiel jetzt keine Mercy mehr. Easy.
Warum zockst du nicht eigentlich Lucio statt dessen? Du bist doch viel geiler.
Ja, weil wir keinen Heal haben sonst. Wir haben eine Moira. Meinst du die heilt irgendwas?
Mit Lucio geht das ja auch.
Wenn du das sagst, ich lass mir das ja zweimal sagen Lucio zu spielen.
Du bringst da die Leute rein und ja, dann mach ich das.
Warum sind eigentlich alle so scharf drauf links zu gehen? Immer.
Also nicht.
Ok, ich geh mal vor.
Das war ein bisschen spät.
Also wenn keiner so Schilddown macht, dann kann ich nix machen.
Und zwar wirklich nix.
Was? Moment, wo ist der Affe hin?
Ich bin gerade mit rein, zack Affe weg.
Ich bin übrigens tot, weil ich reingejolot bin.
Ich komm zu dir.
Oh Gott ey.
Muss ich jetzt wirklich weg sein?
Fuck Alter, da macht ja keiner was.
Ja komm, wir speedboosten da jetzt rein und dann gehts aufs Maul.
So wirklich gut funktioniert das mit Lucio nicht wirklich.
Ich find das sowas von schlimm.
Wenn du zwei Tanks anpackst, da ist so viel Schilder, da kommst du gar nicht mehr durch.
Das ist sowas von gespammelt.
Ich bin übrigens tot, das ist geflammt.
Nur der Kack Hanzo hat dich geflammt.
Also der Typ, der halt wirklich gar nix geschissen kriegt gerade.
Du kriegst alles was ich hab.
Nice und jetzt drauf, jetzt drauf, Speed läuft.
Ich ulti da jetzt, gleich rein.
Die Mei.
Hinter dir, hinter dir.
Ja, ich probiers.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ok, noch mal regroupen.
Regroup so Leute.
Das ist voll fürn Arsch, diese ganze Schildgis bei mir, das geht mir so auf den Sack.
Ok, ok, ok, nicht sterben Leute, nicht sterben.
Go, ja.
Fuck, fu, fu, fu, fu.
Hätte bisschen weiterhüpfen müssen.
Ok, wie viel haben wir gekriegt?
Haben wir überhaupt ein bisschen was gekriegt?
Nix.
Gar nix?
Es wird ja erst auf deinen 30% gezählt.
Ist aber dumm.
Ja, das find ich auch ein bisschen traurig, weil im Prinzip ist ja ja alles Tracking.
Ja.
Aber nee, es muss ja ein Drawer werden können.
Das ist aber echt dumm.
Ich dachte, ich dachte eigentlich in Overtime, also was heißt in Overtime, quasi ab der zweiten Runde oder so, ist dann wirklich so nicht mehr durchkommen,
sondern halt tatsächlich jedes Prozent getrackt.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Leute im Chat, das wollt ihr nicht suchen.
Glaubt mir, das wollt ihr nicht suchen.
Vielleicht dann ihr wollt fürs Leben danach geprägt sein durch sowas.
Es gibt Sachen, da weiß man doch mittlerweile im Jahr 2017 schon, bevor man sucht, wie es ausgeht.
Und wenn man nach solchen Begriffen sucht in Google, da weiß man, oder in Google vielleicht nicht unbedingt, da weiß man doch noch, wie es ausgeht.
Die werden jetzt wieder rumspringen.
Ich kann dir das nicht ansagen, wenn du das nicht siehst.
Fahrer, ich seh da Fahrer.
Moment, was ist das hier?
Ich weiß nicht, sind die rechts durch, hast du was gesehen?
Ich seh nämlich kaum noch was. Ja rechts rechts.
Ich geh wieder, ich geh wieder Main, ich will wieder Main.
Maze, Maze richtig low.
Ich hab'n Fire Strike verkackt.
Die kriegen wir, die kriegen wir.
Ja rechts, der gerade bloß eingelassen.
Ich geh wieder mit in den Fahrer, jawoll, down.
Hier wird, ihr werdet gehämmert.
Jetzt kommt da diese scheiß Kugel da rauf.
Keiner wieder am Start.
Ob die gehen zu rechts, sag mal bitte, ob sie rechts gehen.
Links, links, links.
Gut, was? Oh nee.
Ich brauch Heal, Heal, Heal, Heal.
Oh, ich wollt grad Fire Strike, kacke.
Fuck, Schnub, Schnub.
Wir sind die einzigen, die hier am Brennen sind.
On Fire sind wir hier.
Solide Reinhardt-Plays, muss ich sagen.
Ich hab' wieder Shatter, klar.
Oh, dann los.
Ich glaub', die gehen links, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich glaub', die links gehen sehen.
So, Shatter, Shatter wieder am Start.
Huge, fett Shatter kommt jetzt, richtig fett.
Ich guck mir keine random Videos an, die irgendjemand im Chat pausen.
Zu denen, denen schon gesagt wird, ich soll mal reacten.
Das kann ja schon mal nichts Gutes sein.
Das kann ja schon mal irgendein Blödsinn sein.
Was ist das bitte für eine Hitbox?
Sag mal, kommt da noch jemand?
Das war der Shatter auf Doom.
Das war der Shatter des Todes.
Da waren 6 Leute drinne.
Hast du das gesehen?
Naja, easy.
27%.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass 6 andere Leute in dem Team sind, ne?
Okay, zu was soll ich reacten, zu welchem Video?
Guck dir das mal kurz rein.
Was ist das?
Zum Glück hab ich so einen Vorschauplan.
Das zeig dir gleich an, bevor du das aufmachst, was es ist.
Moneyboy, Monte Carlo, offizielles Musikvideo.
Moneyboy.
Moment, der Typ heißt doch gar nicht mehr Moneyboy, oder?
Heißt der jetzt nicht irgendwie Blak, Blak, Jay Blak?
Oder irgendwie so Blak?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Aber anscheinend heißt er wieder Moneyboy.
Er spielt Golf.
Nee, der hat's doch unbenannt.
Der heißt doch nicht mehr Moneyboy.
Er hat's doch unbenannt jetzt zu...
Genau, wie sein YouTube-Channel heißt.
JSLnoplak.
Alter, was ist das für Musik?
Muss man das irgendwie auf 125% Wiedergabegeschwindigkeit stellen, dass das normal klingt?
Oh, das ist ja schlimm.
Das kann man sich antun.
Wir spielen jetzt lieber, Gibraltar.
Mal genug Moneyboy geguckt.
Jawoll, schön noch neuer Attack.
Bei, eigentlich ist immer Roadhog hier kacke.
Kollegen, ihr könnt Winston spielen.
Mal da hochhüpfen.
Ich probier...
Ich probier's doch mal mit Roadhog, aber nein, ich muss...
Ich muss spielen, was ich spielen muss.
Was meinste?
Ich spiel als Allah.
Sag mal, warum gibt's so wenig Mercy-Mains auf Diamond?
Weil die alle schon quälen.
Ich mein, auf GM...
Hast du mittlerweile Games, da hast du zwei Mercy-Mains, die sich dann anpitchen, wer jetzt Mercy spielen darf.
Und hier, wer muss hier Mercy spielen?
MrFantastic spielt jetzt Mercy.
Pass auf, der Genji-Main ist Genji-Main.
Der spielt bestimmt Mercy.
Nein, Moira.
Ich guck mal, ich guck mal.
Ich halte das denn aus mit Mercy.
Das ist wirklich Folter.
Das geht schon.
Mal gucken, wie viele es waren.
Waren es nur drei, oder was?
Zwei Stück.
Wart mal.
Vier, okay, es waren vier.
Es waren vier.
Ups, es geht los.
Nein, nein, ich bin noch nicht da.
MrFantastic.
Ich muss mal die hier heilen, hier drinnen.
Hast du was? Hast du was gepickt?
Ja, die zwei ist noch angeschossen.
Und da ist der McCree weg.
Sehr schön.
Sag mal, wenn du hinter mir warst, siehst du, ich bin schon da.
Ich bin schon da.
Sehr schön.
Sag mal, wenn du hinter mir warst, siehst du, ich komme mal vorne mit unserem Roadhog.
Das ist ein guter Roadhog, der hat wenigstens ein Schild dran.
Er hält mir.
Ich habe nur drei.
Ich habe Ulti, klar?
Äh...
Da habe ich nicht drauf geachtet, sorry.
Ich habe ja ein Headshot bekommen, du kannst nichts machen.
Ich hab' Ulti am Start.
Takey wokarou!
HUGE SLEEP!
Ich hab' Ulti am Start.
Naja, kein Heimogen.
Alter, wie viele Sniper haben die denn?
Du musst mir sagen, wenn ich dich heilen soll.
Ich guck grad eher zu unseren Tanks vor.
Ihr müsst halt echt pushen und Tanks noch da vorne.
Ich glaub, wir brauchen einen Sniper im Tank.
Wir haben so viele Sniper, der geht nicht.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich bin da alleine drin, ne?
Ihr müsst, ihr müsst pushen. Ich glaub, die rennen mir nach.
Der Reinhardt schläft unten.
Die sind alle unten! Die sind alle unten bei mir!
Help!
Ich bin übrigens tot, ich kann dich nicht heilen.
Der hätten wir so oft schon durch sein müssen jetzt grade.
Echt Wahnsinn.
Kannste Genji spielen oder sowas?
Ja, echt jetzt?
Ich war noch nicht mal sichtbar.
WTF?
Ihr stirbt alles instant.
Nein! D.Va, du Dumme!
Nein, jetzt werden sie auch noch aufgeweckt.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Warum machen wir einfach so die Bombe?
D.Va ist das einzige gescheite Nanoboost-Tagel, was ich hab.
So.
Muss halt doch die Mercy rausgeholt werden.
Es wär halt echt nicht schlecht, wenn wir was zum Diven.
Das war eigentlich der Hintergedanke.
Ich hab gedacht, du boostest jetzt die Nanoboost, du setzt die D.Va,
die fliegt rein, macht ein bisschen Action, killt was.
Nope.
Schretz den Typ mal.
Nein, nein, ich hab einen Tracer auf mir.
Wo bist du?
Null.
Tracer kommt.
Verleben wir das jetzt noch?
Weißt du, die zu...
Also, die PS hat ja keiner mehr.
Es stirbt ja auch keiner.
Was machen die denn?
Da fuck.
Ich komm.
Wtf.
Was ne Pfeife.
Ich geh von below runter, weil ich keinen Impact mit so nem Startup.
Und dann geht er auch below.
Also, ich kann ja wenig grad machen, ne?
Also, der Heil-Out-Problem war nicht mal normal.
Die machen halt alle nicht so viel, ja das stimmt.
Ich bin übrigens tot.
Ich schretz dich, ich schretz dich.
Nein, nein, lass.
Scheiß drauf.
Sind Noobs.
Fuck.
Ich dachte, wir die treffen bestimmt nicht.
Auch wenn Gents Mercy 20 Sekunden stillsteh.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich weiß nicht, es ist ja nur ein Hanzo und ein Witthorn.
Die müssten ja eigentlich nur einmal drauf.
Aber, ja.
Komm.
No Balls.
No Win.
Nein.
Cool.
Da konnt ich dann hin.
Anna gibt mir auch keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch absolut overrated, debated.
Leute, ihr könnt, ihr könnt pushen.
Von rechts den Sniper, rechts den Sniper.
Easy.
Also, ich sag dir ehrlich, ich find die Gents viel anstrengender als alles andere.
Was findest du anstrengender?
Diese, diese Low-Rank-Games.
Das ist, das ist übel, das ist voll der Brainfuck.
Egal.
Die Leute.
Ich seh schon wieder komisch, was wir ausgespielt haben.
Geiler Comment im Chat.
Egal ob ihr die Runde verliert oder gewinnt.
Immerhin konntest du ein bisschen deinen Lieblingsheld spielen.
Jawoll.
Easy.
Das ist schon irgendwie voll, dass du für manchen Spiel abstellst, aber du spürst deinen Raum ein.
Alles, was du tun musst, ist mehr, als du spielst.
Ich wär jetzt geflammt.
Ja gut, was soll ich denn machen?
Bleibt ja nix anderes übrig.
Support dich auch mal.
Jawoll, komm her.
Support du, du und das Todes.
Ist wenigstens die Heilung massig.
Ja, wenn die, wenn die keinen, keinen Genji.
Ja, wenn die bisschen, bisschen was weniger aggressives spielen, geh ich vielleicht auf Zen.
Zen macht übelst Bock.
Ist eigentlich von den Supportern so mit der, der mir am meisten auch Spaß macht.
Aber ist halt, wenn du gar keinen hast, der dich ein bisschen protectet, kannst du klicken.
Bin mal gespannt, wer zuerst den Headshot frisst.
Also ich tippe auf MrFantastik.
MrFantastik.
Tipp auf dich.
Auf mich?
Das kann auch sein.
Nee, guck mal, ich hab die AD-AD-Skills.
Da mir passiert nix.
Und auch, ich kann auch das weggucken, dass man den Kopf nicht trifft.
Ich damage booste dich jetzt.
Die haben Hanzo.
Oh nee.
Skatter, Skatter.
Skatter.
Äh, ich bin runtergetroppt übrigens, weil ich mir dachte so, hä, passt schon.
MrFantastik fast tot gewesen.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir weg hier.
MrFantastik, wo ist er denn hin?
Da hinten.
Oh, wo war der oben?
Den krieg ich nicht, den krieg ich nicht.
Nope.
Oh, die mit auf, fu.
Hast du den Headshot bekommen?
Nee.
Nee, ich war low.
Ich war low.
Ich dachte mir, ich probiere ihn zu retten, weißt du.
Und das war nix.
Max, du hast eine sächsische Stimme.
KappaPride.
Voll KappaPride.
Welcher Rang ist mein Main?
Äh, ich habe es an diesen dreien immer gespielt.
3009 Holland oder so.
Äh, MrFantastik, kann ich geheilt werden?
Wo ist eigentlich MrFantastik?
Ich sehe die Leiche nicht.
Da ist er.
MrLoverLover.
Ist das spannend, Mercy, oder Leute?
Ist das nicht geil?
Ich muss.
Jetzt.
Moment, ich habe meinen Ult gar nicht gebraucht.
Also.
Hinter uns ist eine D.Va.
Komm zu mir.
Halb mich, halb mich.
Easy, easy, easy.
Baschen.
Ist weg.
Also, die Ult war sinnlos.
Ich dachte, da stirbt gleich jemand.
Aber nope.
Oh fuck, fuck, wo?
Also, ich war ein Scattershot.
Highskill, Highoctane Gameplay.
Highoctane Gameplay.
Damage Boost, Alter.
MrFantastik ist verrückt.
Der Hanzo kann doch nicht mal seine Ult auf den Craft aimen.
Aua, Sombra.
Piss dich, Alter.
Scatter, Scatter.
Ui.
Easy.
Highoctane Mercy Gameplay, easy.
Komm, hast du zwei gute Heiler?
Natürlich stehen die Leute wie so ein Steinweiß.
Ich bewerbe mich jetzt am besten noch.
Jett, welches Team hat noch offene, offene Slots?
OVL.
Wer braucht noch Support?
Mercy, Main, EU.
Number one.
Komm, hier.
Easy, easy, Mercy hier.
So ein dummer Held.
Ernsthaft, so dumm.
Ups.
Ja, ich lad dich wieder ein.
Mir fällt gerade auf, es ist schon 23.30 Uhr.
Aber egal.
Ich hab eh Urlaub.
Alter, geht noch ein bisschen.
Ich hab Urlaub.
Scheiß drauf, ja.
Warst du noch nie so lange wach als so oft?
Noch nie.
Das wird dich schlecht.
In meinen 33 Jahren war ich noch nie.
Und gar bis 23.30 Uhr nie.
Ich muss jetzt was futtern, sonst geht das nicht.
Ich nehm dich jetzt auf.
Da kann ich die Mercy-Camp hier hochladen.
Aber es sind eigentlich noch so viele Leute an.
Was ist hier los?
Oh Gott.
Oh.
2CP.
Pablo.
Das ist Pablo.
Wo?
Nein!
Please, no Pablo.
He is.
Haben wir einen Mercy-Main?
Zenyatta-Main haben wir?
Tracer-Main?
Moira-Main?
Doomfist-Main?
Ey, das kann funktionieren.
Was kann funktionieren?
Im Chat wird dein Nickname gelobt.
Echt?
Ja.
Dass es voll Dank-Meme ist.
Nee Dank-Name ist.
Hast du?
Hast.
Dank-Name.
Soldier.
6.
Nein.
Sag ich nicht immer so Soldier 16 999?
Ach fuck, wie hieß das?
420.
Genau.
Soldier 420 hätte es auch noch machen können.
Aber da werden mir ja nicht so coole Sachen eingefallen wie die Kombination hier.
Aber dann sollte sich wirklich mal Vinsow als Nick machen, dann spielst du nur wieder
und Hanzo.
Vinsow.
Moment.
Wir sind Defense.
Warum hab ich jetzt...
Egal.
Ich dachte wir sind Attack.
Wurscht.
Da werden sie gefisstet hier.
Rekt!
Oh.
Rekt jetzt.
Da kommt die wieder um 50 Jahre später.
Ähm, bei mir sind 50 Milliarden Gegner gerade.
Weil irgendwie auf einmal alle Leute weg waren.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Warum waren alle Leute weg auf einmal?
Ähm.
Ich hab irgendwie das dummfe Gefühl, D.Va ist besser.
Ja, ist schon verloren.
Yeah.
Geht gut los.
Sag mal, haben wir überhaupt die PS?
Wir haben...
Naja.
Ich könnte Soldier gehen.
Ich geh jetzt mal Soldier.
Irgendwie hab ich das so immer reden, dass das gut funktioniert.
Oh, unser Reiner hat grad gesetzt, okay.
Oh!
Fuck.
Jetzt haben wir keinen Tank mehr.
Ja, das...
Naja.
Wo ist die wieder?
Moira ist bei uns im Spawn und in der Tracer und...
Sag mal, hier ist ja alles voll!
Alter, was ist denn das hier für ne Dominanz, ey?
Du weißt gar nicht wo du hingucken sollst.
Auf allen Fronten sterben sie.
Ich jump jetzt drauf.
Nice, nice, nice Ulti, nice Ulti.
Wat?
Hü?
Ich hab gleich Weißer.
Brauchen wir aber glaub ich nimmer.
2 CP, lol.
Einschatten sie das Hambursten, wenn es nicht so ein Kackmodus wäre.
Okay.
2 CP, lol, einschatten sie das Hambursten, wenn es nicht so ein Kackmodus wäre.
Okay, ich bin...
Ich hab sie.
Die Moira ist...
Moira haut ab, rechte Seite.
Oder?
Es könnte sein, dass die noch rechte...
Die Moira ist rechte Seite drin, die holen wir jetzt.
Moira, ey, Alter, was ist die für ein Damage, macht das denn nicht normal?
Ich brauch Heal.
Hier.
Nein, ich hab nix mehr.
Ich hab nix mehr.
2 Sekunden, 2 Sekunden, 2 Sekunden.
So.
Easy.
Wir machen das jetzt selbst.
Haha.
Da kann uns uns halt keiner.
Bastion!
Jetzt kann die mit dem Bastion...
Da fuck!
Das bringt ihn aber glaub ich nicht so viel.
Wir müssen einfach außer Sicht stehen bleiben.
Hashtag einfach.
Tank, das war das Schlechteste, was passieren konnte.
Fuck, warum bin ich jetzt...
Oh, ich snoop.
Ich snoop, ich bin voll auf die Bastion zu gerannt.
Warum?
Weil ich aus der D.Va ult wollte, ja, aber dann hätt ich in die andere Richtung rennen
müssen.
Total bescheuert.
Die andere...
Wobei es hätte nix gebracht.
Es hätte nichts...
Es hätte...
Egal welche Richtung, hätte nix gebracht.
Oh, was für Games ey.
Komm, ich spiel jetzt mal Damage.
Easy.
Sie winnen.
Ist vielleicht keine Mercy spielen, ne?
Was?
Was ist denn das?
Oh Mann.
So.
Leute, High Octane Gameplay ist angebracht.
Kann das...
Du hast das ja vorhin so aus Scheiß gesagt, also aus Spaß gesagt, ne?
Kann das sein, dass die halbwegs guten Mercy-Mains wirklich schon alle Köln-Master sind?
Gibt keine guten Mercy-Mains, kannst du das unterlassen?
Das könnte sein, das stimmt, was du gesagt hast, deswegen gibt's hier keine Mercy-Mains
mehr.
Veszka, Late-Stream, ja, mit Telekom-Fail dazwischen.
Ist das jetzt neues Meta, hier rauszugehen, oder wie?
Wir machen jetzt Damage-Mercy.
Das geht mir schon echt auf den Sack, da ich halt so viel Mercy spielen muss.
Gut.
Ey, die Mercy ist still gestanden, ich hab ihr in den Kopf gedrückt.
Body Shot.
Kommst du durch?
Oder willst du nicht durch?
Ja, ja, ich seh's, ich muss aber unsere Leute hinterher...
Leute, Reinhardt, du musst da vorgehen, ist dir schon klar, oder?
Der Reinhardt zackt auf Balls, äh, Reinhardt, oh Gott.
Was ist das hier?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich bleib' auf dir, easy.
Äh, hä?
Warum ging der Red jetzt bitte schön nicht?
What the fuck?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo du bist.
Wo bist du?
Oben.
Oben?
Ah, da.
So, wir gehen jetzt rein.
Die haben, die haben Bastion drin.
Schon wieder.
Ich hab' in den Kopf geschossen.
So, easy.
Body Shot.
Ich hab' ihn gekillt.
Was?
Ich versteh' das nicht, was ist mit der Hit-Trigger im Arsch, ey?
Weiß nicht.
Hab' gleich ult.
Ich weiß übrigens, warum das Ding nicht gerätzt hat eben.
Ich glaub', man darf eh nicht gedrückt halten, wenn man schon mal drauf war, damit er raus
gelaufen ist.
Sondern man muss neu e drücken, weil da die Anzeige ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Aber ich bin halt einfach Mercy-Main erster Stunde, na.
Ich muss sagen, der Mercy-Main EU, äh, ich bin übrigens bei unserem Reinhard unten gerade,
der jetzt mal drauf gehen muss.
Ich...
Meine Mercy-Plays, da chockt er.
Choke Mercy.
Ich wär' so froh, wenn jemand anderes Mercy spielt, oder?
Komm Reinhardt, Reinhardt.
Jetzt.
Jetzt wirst du gehielt.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Willst du mal mehr Mercy spielen, ha, nein!
Oh, Bastion, Bastion.
Ey, der Mollerab, alter, killt mich.
Der ist schon seit ne Stunde da im Rumfliegen.
Reinhardt, swing, swing!
Äh, ich versuch hochzukommen zu dir.
Kannst du?
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Fuck.
Aber wir müssen es auch so packen.
Sagst du.
Fuck.
Meine Mercy-Plays, äh, jetzt in den Earthshatter, wo alles schon tot ist.
Es frustriert mich so, nix machen zu können und Mercy spielen zu müssen.
Also zwei hab ich wenigstens.
Ja, sag mal, sind aber alle tot.
Ich geh jetzt mit dir oben rechts.
Eigentlich haben wir noch einen zweiten Heiler, ne?
Eigentlich.
Genji ist hinter uns.
Geil.
Wenn ich, ich streben schon relativ oft in letzter Zeit, Mercy, please, ich will was
anderes spielen.
Krasse Old Pablo.
Massive Old, Massive.
Ich hab hinten.
Ey, die gehen nur auf mich.
Reinhardt, hallo, Reinhardt.
Hallo, der Graz, go go, easy clap, easy.
Können wir mal rein?
Nein, können wir anscheinend nicht.
ETF.
Jetzt aber, jetzt aber, ich, ich damage booste dich jetzt, easy, machst du platt.
So, ich bleib einfach bei dir stehen, hinter uns, hinter uns ist eine Moira.
Rechts, Soldier, damage boost, easy, Achtung, Genji rechts, schreckt, hardcore schreckt,
das machen wir jetzt immer so, ich spiel Mercy, du spielst Winner und ich stell mich einfach
neben dich und mach damage boost.
Genau.
Das, ich, ich, ich mein, man muss doch ehrlich sagen, das ist für ein Stream auch das Beste,
da kann ich nämlich ordentlich Fragen im Chat beantworten, wenn ich das mache.
Also das verbindet, das, das, das verbindet quasi das Beste aus zwei Welten.
Oh man.
So.
Mal gucken, was jetzt, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich keine Mercy picke.
Wir verlieren.
Weißt du?
Natürlich.
Warum?
Ich will was ordentliches spielen.
Mich wundert das, wir haben die ganze Zeit einen Junkrat im Team, aber ich bin Gold-Damaged,
was macht der die ganze Zeit?
Als ob du mit Widow Gold kriegst.
Guck mal, ich bin Mercy und bin nur Bronze-Heal, ja?
Aber ich hab ja auch die ersten zwei Runden keine Mercy gespielt.
Oh man.
Ja, du musst ja eh nicht heilen, wenn du auf mir damage boost machst.
Nee, das ist kein Ding, easy.
Auch schon hier.
Hier ist es absolut overrated.
Outdated, eliminated, overrated, debated is heal.
Guck, wie ob da ein Play-off der Game von mir dabei ist am Ende.
Ich hoffe es.
Das war richtig geil.
Das war richtig geil, du hast die Jubels weggespread da unten.
Also was heißt gesprayed?
Geklickt, geklickt, weggeklickt.
Gerade der Genji hat schön ins Gesicht bekommen.
Ich komm nicht hoch zu dir.
Jetzt, easy, easy.
Genji hinter mir.
Die haben schon wieder einen Reaper.
Hinter uns der Genji, ich muss die Orissa mal heilen.
Die checkt es nicht, die geht nicht weg.
So, ich bin auf dir, siehst du was?
Ich hör rechts was.
Hinter uns, Reaper hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns.
Nein, von den Spiegel.
Geht zurück und spawnen.
Was, du?
Warum?
Damit ich schießen kann.
Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy,
easy.
Oh Gott, diese Sch- aaaah, Moira ist so ein Drecks- Ding, ey.
Was?
Was willst du, was willst du wenig?
Hä, wenig, was?
Nein.
Oh oh, oh oh, help, help, help, help, help.
Wo bist du?
Ein Stück da.
Damage boost, ich bleibe jetzt auf dir wieder.
Beste Taktik, so, easy, easy mode.
So.
Hä, ich geh mal spawnen, Rektangeln.
Wenig, du kannst doch Deutsch, red doch Deutsch mit mir, ich weiß nicht, was du willst.
Ey, sch- nein, nein, jetzt, gleich, gleich kommt der Rats, huge stress.
Komm, wir gehen high ground, abrutscht.
Ich bin schon da, easy, komm.
Merci.
Was?
Neiiin, ich hab ult gewaistet, ich hab ult gewaistet, lol.
Jetzt kommen die Counterplates des Todes.
Ich hab ult gewaistet, wasted, baited, meine Mercy Plane ist einfach legendär, wie man
sieht, aber nichtsdestotrotz, es war die beste Entscheidung, das basiert auf Erfahrung der
letzten Runde, einfach Damage Boost durchgedrückt halten.
Richtig.
So, easy.
Tschüss, tmra66.
Weil mich wundert das, was da abging, ey, die Mercy war grad auf dem Spot, hat's irgendwie
geheilt, stand still, ich immer so ne Sekunde Zeit, zieh auf den Kopf, drück ab, oh, you
shot.
Hä?
Komisch.
Ich hab zum ersten Mal jetzt gecheckt, dass man mit Mercy Space gedrückt halten kann zum
Klaiten, greetings, ich bleib jetzt hier stehen, da kann mir nix passieren, easy, Orisa, wie
wär's mit nem zweiten Schild?
Hä, Orisa?
Nein, worbei nicht.
Tracer, ich hab ne Tracer rechts gehört, rechts Tracer, ich hab ne Tracer rechts gehört,
rechts Tracer, ist ätzend, ne, komm jetzt links, einer, rechts ist die Tracer wieder,
Mist ist auf dir drauf, ey, stopp, Achtung, zu dir, jaja, bin drauf, Achtung, die Tracer
ist rechts, fuck, hä, hä, warum ging der Herz jetzt nicht, ich hab doch eh gedrückt,
darf man sich da nicht bewegen oder was, aber weißt du das, ja, jetzt gibt's draw, ich
weiß gar nicht, was soll ich denn da noch machen, ey, ich heal die ganze Zeit, aber
monitor direkt, noch ein extra, livestream, ja, ne, kneej看到 zwei, 250,antwort, ne,
Die kommen rechts oder nicht?
Egal, du machst das schon.
Ich hab dich, ich hab Heal auf dich.
Ich hab dich, du machst das schon.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, echt jetzt.
Echt jetzt.
Ey, das, das, das könnt ihr nicht machen, mann.
Ich bin's, ich mach jetzt Soldier.
Wie viele soll ich denn noch killen?
Ich hab's, ich hab's, pass.
Hinter uns ist ein Genji am Spawn.
Hab ihn.
Äh, soll ich zurückswitchen?
Äh, ja, ja, ja.
Wobei wir echt ein DPS Problem haben.
Also ich, ich hab so das Gefühl, ich bin komplett alleine.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Oben links kommt was.
Ich, ich komm zu dir zum Damage boosten.
Hast du nen Visor oder sowas?
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich hab mich übelst gedeift, rechte Seite.
Ich komm wieder mit Soldier.
Ich bleib' Soldier.
So, 24 Minuten für den Job.
Jawoll, yeah.
Geil.
Beste Runde.
Doc Mimmi, moin.
Ich seh's schon, du hast Mercy Main Channels abonniert.
Was soll ich dazu sagen, Doc Mimmi, ha?
Das war, das war übrigens gerade die Königsdisziplin.
Das war 2CP, Mercy, Gameplay und Raw.
Das, äh, äh, also, oh fuck.
Ich hab.
Also, mein, mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht verabschieden.
Ich hab das, ich hab das, ich hab das, ich hab das.
Ich hab das, ich hab das, ich hab das.
Also mein, mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht verlangen von diesem Game.
Doch, Mimmi, ich hab nix gegen Mercy mains.
Ich frag mich nur, wo die Mercy mains in meinen Games sind, dann müsste ich nicht Mercy spielen.
Ich finde Mercy mains super, solange sie bei mir im Game sind.
Danke für die Follows.
Ich hab ein Twitch-Achievement unlocked. Teilzeit, Vollzeit, Überstunden, 1.
Okay, was sagt dieses Achievement?
Dieses Achievement sagt...
Teilzeit, Vollzeit, Überstunden.
Streame innerhalb von 30 Tagen insgesamt 25 Stunden.
Wo Hiyo streame regelmäßig, um weitere Zuschauer anzulocken,
dann kann ich die Achievement unlocken.
Streame innerhalb von 30 Tagen insgesamt 25 Stunden.
Wo Hiyo streame regelmäßig, um weitere Zuschauer anzulocken,
finde dabei die richtige Balance für dich.
Krasser Lifehack.
Das ist ja...
Dass ich die richtige Balance für mich finden muss beim Streamen ist schon...
Mein Plan.
Alsberger, was für ein Rank bist du?
Inosaki, es geht ja grad drum, dass ich bisschen wieder in das Game reinkomme.
Wenn wir uns jetzt einen Top-500-Spieler oder so holen...
Boah, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube der Eax ist auch nicht so weit von Top-500 entfernt.
Dann ist ja der Lerneffekt nicht da.
Der Lerneffekt ist auch nicht da, wenn ich die ganze Zeit Mercy spielen muss.
Allein nicht Mercy.
Ach, ich will Mercy nicht lernen.
Kommst du da, Kratz?
GZ.
Good Job, GZ.
So, Eax ist weg.
Oh, weil der Pizzadar ist, was haben wir hier für Musik?
Beste...
Beste Party-Metal...
Die Skipped.
Hey, hey.
Du kriegst gleich Bann, warum krieg ich Bann?
Ich bin doch nicht mein Partner.
Du kriegst gleich BAN, warum krieg ich BAN?
Ich bin doch nicht euer Partner
Was soll ich gebannt werden?
Also nicht ich, wollte ich grad sagen, LOL
Kannst go machen
Okay, weil ich muss erstmal Musik ausmachen
Ja, mit dem Friseur nehm ich im Dezember was auf
Next
Mit dem Kabu muss ich mal gucken, hab ich noch nicht gefragt
Denk ich auch
Ich hab eh, wie gesagt, ich hab eh vor diesem Monat
Einiges aufzunehmen
Mit mehreren Leuten
Ihr braucht ein Mercy-Monstery-Pony, bin zwar noch keins, kann aber noch werden
Wenn du das wirklich machen willst, dann viel Spaß
Ich kann's dir nicht empfehlen
Das ist der Wahnsinn
Ich hab mir jetzt schon, jetzt bin ich im Bein, aber ich glaub mal so 120 Punkte plus gemacht
Ja
Das sind halt die übelsten Diamond-Accounts, das dauert halt erstmal ein bisschen
Das hab ich mir jetzt schon gefehlt, aber ich glaub mir, ich hab jetzt schon 120 Punkte plus gemacht
Ja
Das dauert halt erstmal ein bisschen, jetzt hab ich hier Statistik
18 Lost, 24 Won
Das ist nicht so oder was, das ist nicht so, dass du da hier erstmal 80 SR Boost kriegen wirst pro Game
Aber du kommst da halt nur mit Grind raus
Weil's einfach total random ist
Mittlerweile, was du so kriegst
Ich mein, klar, im Durchschnitt kann man immer noch sagen, ja, wenn du lang genug spielst
Und immer alles gibst
Dann hast du genauso viel Scheißgegner gegen dich, wie du im eigenen Team hast und bla bla bla
Aber
Ehrlich
Wenn du nicht grad richtig guter Tracer, Genji-Spieler oder sowas bist, ist das wirklich
Ist halt harter Grind, der echt frustrierend ist
Klar, man kommt raus, jeden tut das
Auf jeden Fall
Ich fand das früher aber wesentlich einfach, hochzukommen
Ja, in Zeiten von Ana-Meter zum Beispiel, da konntest du, wenn du Ana gut gespielt hast, konntest du
Von Bronze bis GM, konntest du Ana spielen
Easy
Wie generell, also in Zeiten, wo einfach keine Mercy da war, die 10 Ultimates rief
Ja, das stimmt
Das frustrierend daran ist halt auch, dass selbst, wenn du jetzt ein richtig geiles Play gemacht hast
Kommt die Mercy, drückt eine Taste, das war für'n Arsch
Das ist halt echt das, das ist auch wirklich das frustrierend, dagegen zu spielen
Mal angenommen, du machst jetzt
Let's match this, we don't
Du machst den übelst geilen hier, Flick, Headshot, sonst was, Bam, Gegner tot, wichtiges Target tot
Mercy, Highskill, E
So
Fertig
Du musstest halt die übelste Sache aufwenden
Das Shatter to Kay, bestimmt der real Shatter to Kay
Nein, ich spiel keine Mercy diesmal
Ich seh's, ich seh's kommen, ich seh's kommen
Ich seh's, nein
Ist egal
Also wenigstens zwei Off-Tanks, ne
Hier so ein Dual-Premate, du hast ein Off-Tank, so, das ist schon mal fein
Wir Ego-Maden haben wir hier, die bleiben wir hier
Ich hab die ganze Zeit Mercy gespielt
Wir spielen
Ich geh mal in den Team-Chat, ob die ein bisschen rum
Ding sind
Wir haben beste, beste Voraussetzungen mit dieser Comp, ja
Ich seh's kommen, ich muss, ich muss jetzt
Lass dich mal überraschen, vielleicht gewinnen wir das sogar mit der Scheiß-Combo
Also ich kann doch nicht permanent Mercy spielen, dann uninstall ich ja, obwohl wir gewinnen
4 DD und zwei Tanks, ja, perfektes, perfektes Setup, ja, perfekt
Warum hab ich eigentlich so ein Kack-Fadenkreuz beim Roadhog
Kein Wunder, dass ich keinen Hoax treff
Die, die, die sind hart drauf, oder
Die wollen das, die wollen das jetzt wirklich spielen mit zwei Tanks und
Und No-Heal
Okay, er hat eine Ana geswitcht
Ach nee, Mercy hat E gedrückt, das Glück ist, was ich gesagt hab
Was? Wie Orisa einfach mal pre-chumpt, so ohne zu wissen, was Sache ist
Ha came
Pfuh
Heal gibt keinen Heal
Das ist wieder so ein Game-Äh, was ist das hier
Ah, was ist das hier
Das ist eigentlich schon so ein game was fast schon wieder lost ist von vorm anfang an
Kannst du auch nichts machen
Was sollst du da machen?
Du machst da ein orisa schild da und da kommt schon das nächste
Das ist echt lächerlich gerade
Ich meine da kannst du halt nichts machen jetzt ist nicht möglich da was was ist deine peak max 3000 was hatte ich diesen drei auf dem man 3900 4050 keine ahnung
Ich bin jetzt schon da
Okay
Nice, aber ich dachte das hast du gescopt gerade
das ist echt hardcore lächerlich grade ey das gibt's doch net
perfekt perfektes game beste bestes game heute des tages
wann hast du das letzte mal wieder aus upload gezogen
vorgestern oder so das ist halt das ist so ein typisches game das ist ist das ist lost
voll anfang an das einfach instant lost ist ja nicht aber ich habe jetzt auch
kein bock gegen so eine combo irgendwie was ernsthaftes zu picken also wenn du
schwende schon siehst dass instant die tolle 2 tank 4 dps combo ran start
gebracht wird nicht deswegen was meinst du dieses ganze schild kann ich
verstehen das kann ich verstehen dass wir haben eine gescheite eine gescheite
komp hätten wir das mal im attack gehabt das ist alle mal besser als den kack
der mal im attack ohne schild ohne hiel irgendwann an anna hallo eiskäuter
und so das ist kein salz das ist fakt seit wann ist zwei tanks 4 dps eine gute
spielbar komp und ich sehe es auch nicht ein immer den hell zu spielen mit mir
hast du den ich am wenigsten gerne spiele also immer das war die letzten die
letzten vier games oder so
finde ich auch immer mega zum kotzen auf mein main eigentlich pick ich ja immer
das was keine andere was macht eigentlich die orissa da ich glaube die will jetzt
einfach dastehen bleiben und losen oder ja okay es beste bestes ei malerzeiten
ey was geht denn hier ab die sterben einfach nicht mehr
egal das gelb ist vorbei easy win so kannst du weiter
naja gescheite kommt geht anders hast du gesehen mit was wir detect haben
comments zwei tanks 4 dps perfekt das sind so games die sind für anfangen
halt für den arsch
wir spielen jetzt nicht mehr mit als mit zwei leuten du hast das höchste
gefühle theoretisch kannst du dir dann auch sagen spielst du six deck gewinnt
alles bis zu einem gewissen rang aber da kriegst keine sr wenn du einen hohen sr
hast so diese ganzen schießleute die hohen sr haben und dann erst mal in der
im six deck rumgammeln und ein game die woche machen auf dem account dass er
oben bleiben das hat er damals als evermore gemacht
kannst du noch erinnern dieser 5k rothog in korea hat hochgespielt und hat
auch mit übelst guten leuten gespielt hat er ein game die woche gemacht mit
six deck zum halten
haben wir jetzt jetzt mal leute dabei haben wir haben ich guck mal wenn so
port spieler haben jetzt jetzt werden wir geflammt jetzt werden wir geflammt
jetzt haben wir als jetzt haben wir mal sehen kommen wir naja ich meine besser
als nix vor allem wir sind dran schuld an letzter runde eindeutig hat man ja
gesehen
ensner der evermore der auf gamescom pupke gewonnen hat kann sogar sein da
hat gesagt er wird als pupke spieler
es ist egal ich komme ich werde weggesnabt dann haben wir keine rest gut
möglich
Ich dropp dann gleich runter
Geil
So, ich kontest jetzt
Ich muss weg
Schießt unser Junkrat eigentlich Granaten oder?
Ich brauch HEALT!
Oh, asleep, fuck
Heal please, heal please
Wir haben halt kaum HEAL
Das ist definitiv nicht der real Shatter
Ich bleib am Payload stehen
Ich hab' die Karte, ich hab' die Karte
DASBAY
After a morp aufm winsten
Und der ist halt rapid. Das ist so krass
Ich brauch các
Was haben wir jetzt grade für Games?
Loll
Zen willst du nicht zurückgehen?
So Leute ich geh jetzt vor
Tracer fast down
Jetzt sind wir schön gegeneinander gechargt
Warum krieg ich denn keine Heals?
Das gibt's doch nicht
Und warum stirbt der Reihard nicht obwohl er gestunt ist?
Das ist ja gerade schrecklich
Das ist unglaublich oder?
Frag mich was die meiste Heilung momentan ist
Outplayed hat der Mischter Reinhard
Jetzt haben wir überhaupt keine Heiler mehr
Was sind das denn für Spezialisten wieder?
Was fällt das hinter uns?
Was sind das wieder für Spezialisten?
Okay so kann ich kein Reinhard spielen das funktioniert nicht
Ich muss irgendwas mit Selbstheal spielen
Jetzt kannst du vollknicken
Hallo Roadhog fetter Sack spring da mal hoch
Ich höre am wenigsten rechts von uns
Und ich höre hinter Tracer drin
Wir müssen jetzt contesten
Nice, nice snipesore
Warum hat er das überlebt?
Er ist extrem lau
Was ist denn hier los?
Fünf von mir bitte
Junkrat spamme da
Ich stehe hier gleich da unten
Ich weiß doch schon wieder hinter mir ey
Was ist down?
Tester
Denkst du das ist weg?
Das gibt es ja in der Stadtrandsterbe obwohl ich den Healstrahl drauf habe
Was ne Runde ey
Aber vom Flame her kann es ja echte Shatter sein das hat er sich abgeguckt
Soll ichs machen?
Was denn?
Also mit den zwei Heilern hast du eh keinen Heiler
Da kannst du immer aus hier reinpicken
Ja machst meinen Personal Damage Booster das wird schon reichen
Du musst jetzt noch in den Chat schreiben Personal Damage Booster
Ist es egal was ihr in den Chat schreibt dann ist instant das Geflame angesagt
Ich hoffe mal die Gegner nutzen hier keine Schild Spam Scheiße
Kann man in Overwatch auch ohne Team bisschen was reißen es macht auf jeden Fall mit Team am meisten Spaß
So viel kann man sagen denk ich
Du kannst Solokyo spielen aber die Erfüllung ist das auch nicht
Da muss man halt ab und zu mal den sauchen Apfel beißen und den Held spielen den man am wenigsten mag am wenigsten kann
Was auch immer bei Mercy so alles zu können gibt und da muss man halt durch
Ich seh dich 10.000 Mal verfehlt
Ich muss den Hawk heilen
Sag wenn du Heal brauchst
Links ist der Hawk
Ich komm zu dir
Mach weg
Pass auf ich hab Angst vom Hawk
Ich brauch hier
Hilfe Hilfe
Vor allem es gibt so viele Mercy Mains wo sind die alle jetzt wieder
Der ist halt echt so wenn ich es nicht mache macht es keiner
Achtung der Zen wird gepoppt
Ich hab einen Winston
Das hat mich geahnt
Dieser Held
Kriegst du das nicht mit wenn ich das spätt
Panzer ist weg
Junk ist weg
Da guck ich sag doch wenn ich das nicht mach
Ich seh dich grad nicht von hier aus
Da kommen jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr Achtung bei dir oben ist ein Hanzo
Das waren die sickes Schatz des Todes mann
Kannst du mich mal hochfliegen lassen zu dir
Ich versteck mich ich hab Schiss
Kannst du mich reißen
Pass auf
Ich muss mal ein bisschen heilen vorne
Hallo Leute ich muss euch sehen dass ich euch heilen kann
Ich bin weggekickt worden vom Affe
Harambe
Easy win
Ja zeig Podge her
Kommt noch Battlefield 3
Nein heute nicht
Es ist 0 Uhr 22 ich fang jetzt kein neues Game mehr an
Du bist doch nicht so gar mod beim Friseur
Extrem der Friseur auf Twitch
Gib mal noch nen Tag da können wir nicht mehr Q'en
Die Sick Mercy Plays haben sich nicht mal gelohnt
Es ist so absurd dass das Game keine Team Q hat
Er hat ja vor über einem Jahr schon gesagt sie wollen in einem Clan System oder sie arbeiten in einem Clan System
Das könnte man doch machen
Ich spiele mal wieder Speed
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal die Stats vom real Shadow 2K an
Warum sind eigentlich alle so geiler drauf Moira zu spielen?
Und neuer Held wahrscheinlich
Ich hab rechts was gehört
Ganz schön viel hier
Rechts Seite rechts Seite
Was war das für ein Hook?
Was soll ich farm?
Ich hab Ulti
Ich muss unseren Harambe der sich jetzt gerade hinter der Säule versteckt hat
Hast du nicht abgekriegt?
Wie knapp hätte nur einer mehr drauf geschossen auf dieses Tier wäre es weg gewesen
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Irgendwo haben die einen Sniper
Ich hab Heal an mehr kann ich dann machen
Bustio endlich war wieder lange nicht mehr gehabt
Ich wurde bestimmt schon seit 5 Monaten nicht mehr geboostet
Links oben
Ich muss hier laufen lassen
Ich hab sie
Die Gegner werden aber ganz schön weggefickt gerade
Hier oben liegt eine Trap
Ich bin hier außen ich lebe noch ich lebe noch ich komme zurück
Ich hab ulti
Huge Ult
Ich hab Ulti
Jetzt hab ich ihn aufgeweckt
Nicht
Jetzt müssen wir aber drauf
Das gibt es doch nicht
Da schießt doch keiner drauf oder so
Wir hätten die bei einigen Files einschalten müssen
Das geht dauernd
Die sterben
Ich muss mal unsere Orisa heilen kurz
Gute Frage
Das verstehe ich auch nicht
Wie konnte man das denn jetzt verlieren Alter
Ich bin übrigens in der Meta
Ich bin in der Meta
Huge Masi Place
Hinter uns hinter uns andere Seite außen
Ich muss weg
Ich muss den Typen retzen
Was ist so brain
Huge
Es war massiv war das
Jetzt geht es ab
Das andere geiler war
Huge Masi Place
Ist wirklich schlimm dass man so viel Masi spielen muss
Wundert mich
So aus Streams
Ich sonst so gucke ist ja alles voll
Mit irgendwelchen Masi Mains
Die sind alle Grandmaster
Ich würde sagen machen wir morgen weiter
Ich gehe jetzt pennen
Das reicht
Wie viel hast du jetzt
Ich dachte du hast mich überholt
Ich kann ja selbst gucken
Ich gucke mal
Das passt doch
Gibt es irgendjemand den man hosten kann
Kamikaze den können wir hosten
Der freut sich bestimmt
Also Leute
Macht es gut bis zum nächsten Mal
Tschüss
Geil
das bin.
LOL.
Upstream.